well I woke up this morning and I said
to myself sir we should really do a show
today there's a lot going on and so here
we are that's the context in which
today's program is is being produced One
programming note dozens of people
writing to me uh breathlessly you could
tell even though though it was written
text that people were breathless saying
David when is your Lex Friedman
appearance coming out I don't know the
answer but I Lex said it would be three
or four days from when we filmed it
earlier this week
so I would guess by the end of this week
but I don't know and I don't have any
control over it but I'm as I'm as eager
to take a look at it as some of the
other folks in the audience are so we'll
know about that very very soon all right
listen I've been waiting for this and it
is now happening Republicans
right-wingers Maga types Stephen Crowder
and others
are now coming after what we call no
fault divorce which essentially
translates to they want to force women
to have to stay married unless they can
give what some consider an acceptable
reason for why they should be allowed to
get divorced what on Earth am I talking
about let's backtrack and let's set it
up I had no plan to talk about
right-wing content creator Stephen
Crowder's divorce on the podcast there's
really just no reason to talk about it I
don't know there's nothing particularly
newsworthy about it except when I
watched his brief explanation of the
personal trouble that he's having and
including this very contentious divorce
he seemed to sort of bemoan the fact
that his wife can just say hey I want a
divorce and it's called no fault divorce
you don't have to prove that someone
cheated or whatever
uh to justify the divorce you're just
allowed to say I don't want to be in
this marriage anymore and in the video
that Stephen Crowder
um put out about this he seemed to be
sort of suggesting that that's a problem
that that's not okay his wife maybe
should be forced to stay married to him
and he's not the only one who feels this
way let's take a listen this is the
video from I guess now it's been about a
week since this news broke to the extent
that it's news uh I have been living
with a proverbial boot on my neck for
going on years now
uh since 2021 I've been living through
what has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say on the outset to
be clear there is no infidelity any kind
of physical abuse at all on either side
and no this was not
my choice my then wife decided that she
didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted
it's permitted it's allowed as crazy as
it is you're just allowed to say I don't
want to be married anymore and I can't
control that so this is now building
into a bigger Story and there's a very
interesting Rolling Stone article the
next front in the Republicans war on
women no fault divorce Stephen Crowder
is part of a growing right-wing chorus
calling for an end to Modern divorce
laws and the article explains and you
can check it out Stephen Crowder is
getting a divorce he says it's not his
choice he says his wife is just allowed
to do it and the article says Crowder's
emphasis on the state of Texas makes it
sound like the Lone Star State is an
outlier but all 50 states in the
District of Columbia have no fault
divorce laws on the books laws that
allow either party to walk away from an
unhappy marriage without having to prove
abuse infidelity or other misconduct
Republicans are now unsure whether this
is something that they actually want and
the article goes on to say uh
like the Crusades against abortion and
contraception making it more difficult
to leave an unhappy marriage is about
control Crowder's home state could be
the first to eliminate it if the Texas
Republican party gets its way last year
the Republican party of Texas added
language to its platform calling to an
end to no fault divorce this is another
way to potentially control women that's
what this is fundamentally about no
fault divorce is a legal process which
basically just means you can end a
marriage without having to prove that
any spouse is at fault for the breakdown
of the marriage and the history of no
fault divorce in the United States goes
back to the early 20th century but it
really wasn't until the 1970s that no
fault divorce had widespread acceptance
and before you had no fault divorce I
sound like Trump many people don't know
this
a lot of people have no reason to think
about this but before there was no fault
divorce divorce laws in the U.S were
based on fault and what that meant is in
order to be granted a divorce in order
to be allowed to get a divorce one
spouse had to prove that the other
spouse was at fault for the failure of
the marriage and often it was adultery
cruelty some kind of Abandonment like
they basically left already anyway
sometimes insanity or or you know what
we might call mental illness and then in
the 60s and 70s states started to
rightfully reconsider that and say Hey
you know maybe people in the same way
that they can choose to get married
should just be allowed to choose to no
longer be married anymore and California
was the first to pass no fault divorce
in 1969 and then by the end of the 1970s
Most states had done the same thing the
really important thing to understand
here aside from what I believe to be the
obvious logic that you shouldn't have to
make a case to be allowed to get
divorced you should just be able to say
I don't want to be married anymore it's
worth mentioning that no fault divorce
significantly improved the lives of
women as well as children in many
situations by giving them greater legal
protections and more Equitable outcomes
in divorce proceedings now there is
you'll have the men's rights activists
who love to say uh men routinely and and
sort of systematically get screwed over
when it comes to custody in divorce
proceedings and it's unfair and all
these different things I consider that
to be a different issue that can be
discussed on its merits but understand
that prior to the introduction of no
fault divorce particularly because it
was during an era where women were
statistically less likely to work or if
they work they were statistically likely
to to be earning less money than the
husband in a heterosexual marriage they
were more likely to be dramatically
disadvantaged and controlled by the lack
of no-fault divorce and so no no fault
divorce as obvious as it is to many of
us and as standard as it is in so many
other Western developed Nations it
actually was a really significant change
uh and and liberating to some degree
[Music]
providing additional rights to many
women as it became more common during
the 1970s so it's not a surprise given
that Republicans love policy that uh
allows women to be controlled let's
control what women can do with their
bodies let's control medically Etc given
all of that it's not a surprise that
they've found yet another issue on which
they want to go back to the 1950s and
again that's quite literally what we're
talking about this was the law of the
land in the 1950s started changing 69
into the 70s I had an inkling when I saw
the Crowder video
they're gonna go after this no-fault
divorce and now that is in and of itself
becoming a bigger story horrifying stuff
but it is the party it is the movement
of going back to the 1950s all right I'm
I'm not going to talk about this every
day but there is something very
interesting happening with this
forthcoming CNN town hall with Donald
Trump yesterday I told you that CNN has
announced they will be holding a town
hall with failed former and wannabe
future president Donald Trump and I
express concerns that they're treating
him like he's a normal person they're
treating him like he's just yet another
presidential candidate not a guy who
incited a riotous Insurrection not a guy
who's been indicted and arrested once
and potentially will be again
now getting another 24 hours of uh time
for CNN to promote this event
they're really pretending like he is a
normal candidate here is a promo from
yesterday morning on CNN including uh
the thoughts of Caitlin Collins who will
be the host or anchor of that
forthcoming Town Hall so a quick
programming note is
as we were watching Paul
and Trump is going to take questions
from New Hampshire primary voters and an
exclusive seat in town hall I'm in a
modern set of it next Wednesday May 10th
at 9pm Eastern so looking forward to
seeing that uh really important for him
to take voter questions he is the front
runner right now in the GOP new
overnight Sam yeah so listen he's the
GOP front runner it's that simple it's
going to be interesting to hear a man
sir oh how will you keep in the
undocumented immigrants out this is not
looking particularly good it looks like
this is becoming 2016 part two the
normalization of absolute extremism our
Argentinian friend who's been a guest on
the program expert on fascism Federico
Finkelstein tweeted quote this is how
the normalization of wannabe fascist
populism happens and then here is a
little promo on CNN for the event former
president Donald Trump takes questions
live from CNN's Caitlin Collins and New
Hampshire GOP Primary voters their
issues their concerns their votes a CNN
Republican Presidential Town Hall there
you go so like I said yesterday I
totally understand why CNN is doing this
it couldn't be better timed you've got
millions of people furious with Fox News
because of they they fired Tucker and
these different things they've gone woke
um they settled the Dominion lawsuit and
they're looking for somewhere to go and
maybe that somewhere is going to be CNN
now as I said before I'm not opposed on
principle to having an event with Trump
but it must be handled correctly and
responsibly and it can't just be hey New
Hampshire voters ask about what Trump's
gonna do about woke and trans you have
to make it clear
that this is a dishonest
paranoid
narcissistic conspiracy theorist with
things in his recent past that have
never been seen from the American
presidency and that none of this is
normal can Caitlyn Collins do that sure
will she do it I don't know my plan is
to cover the town hall live I know
people will say but David aren't you
doing the same thing CNN is doing no
this is a media analysis show and an
American politics show and one of the
things we do is look at how Corporate
media covers something like Trump uh and
we're going to be doing it responsibly
and if they uh rehabilitate His Image
and if they don't do the things that
they should be doing we will call it out
so my hope is to cover that live we
might get shut down by CNN as you know
that's happened to us in the past with
these
um exclusive events but that'll be next
week we'll take a quick break much more
to talk about today first
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right now I promise I'm not going to
do this every single day but it's just
too delightful not to briefly talk about
it on Tucker Carlson's latest
replacement second night filling in for
the now fired Tucker Carlson on Fox News
Lawrence Jones again just made a
complete and total fool out of himself
yesterday we talked about it and I said
hey you know what guys this guy may not
be ready for prime time he just doesn't
really seem to have what it takes to put
it very likely uh he was on again
yesterday and it's confused word salad
after confused word salad from Lawrence
Jones
it's I almost am feeling a little bad
for him like isn't it so obvious he's
nowhere even remotely close to ready to
do this he had a Democrat I guess he's
usually called Democratic strategist
Julian Epstein on
and
I mean he tries to make some point and
it's just so confusing it's it's really
a trumpian word salad listen to this
the Democrats say that that this is a
race issue when I I I just can't help
but look at history when it came for
black Americans that came across the
border unwillingly it took three
constitutional amendments and an entire
War to get black Americans the right of
average Day American
citizens so why do the Democrats have a
different application of the law here I
I just have no clue what he's talking
about it's something about brown people
from Mexico
being treated differently he seems to be
saying we needed civil war to end
slavery of black people
but Democrats want to treat
brown people from Mexico different I I
just don't even know what he's talking
about and this is the reaction from
people who are still watching this which
is not that many people I have to tell
you he's just not very good at this
there was another segment where he had
Lee Fang Li Fong on who's been a guest
on the program and I guess he's trying
to Lawrence Jones is trying to explain
the First Republic Bank failure which we
talked about yesterday on the
award-winning globally famous bonus show
and I don't know he says something about
diversity and I don't even know what
he's talking about yeah so they
recruited all these minorities and their
bank's still filled so all the
minorities that bank that the there
they're screwed uh the governor
government is saying they're going to
help them but it just doesn't seem like
they solved the problem Lee thanks so
much for joining the program okay I
don't know what he means by they're
screwed I mean JPMorgan Chase bought the
bank
there's FDIC insurance it's not the
government's going to do something
special to bail bail them out they're
just there is FDIC insurance and so
their deposits are are insured visibly
confused throughout the entire hour I
don't think Lawrence Jones is going to
be the eventual replacement to Tucker
Carlson but listen I could be wrong we
will have to wait and see this almost
slipped by me but one of our viewers
Alan wrote to me about it and we have to
look at it
former Trump propagandist Stephen Bannon
actually sat down and did a long-form
interview with the failed former
president Donald Trump and it's
fascinating because this is this is sort
of like a vicious circle that we're
going to look at here
Trump tells many of the lies during this
interview with Steve Bannon
that arguably Steve Bannon created or at
least Bannon created the sort of
approach to politics that leads to Trump
being so comfortable telling these lies
it's really interesting to see
I guess you could say
the chef eating his Protege food I don't
know exactly what metaphor or analogy
makes sense so let's look at some of
this the formatting this is from
America's real America's voice war room
with Steve Bannon and their video player
is a mess and technologically it's all a
mess so I'm going to have to kind of
scrub through the video to moments that
my colleague John flagged for me the
first thing here is after years of the
whole crooked Hillary thing which Trump
recently reassigned to Crooked Joe Biden
Trump now is saying he never actually
thought crooked Hillary was that great
of a nickname which is weird because he
used it for half a decade I have old
problem but yeah I think they like to
say that for other reasons you know like
to say he's got a big problem now
because you've given him a nickname
I decided that
I've decided that Hillary's cooked uh we
can't do too much better you know I
always felt I never felt the Crooked
Hillary was a great name I thought it
was accurate but it never flowed like
some of the other half letters in here
from Bill Clinton you talk about it so
let's be really Frank okay do you think
when Bannon says that this this
interview was clearly done the day after
the rally at which Trump announced I'm
changing crooked Hillary to Crooked Joe
Biden do you think Bannon really thinks
that it's a big deal for Trump to change
the nicknames or is Bannon just playing
the sycophant suck up
that people around Trump are expected to
play uh I don't know I don't know the
answer to that all right let's now go
and bear with me here this is just the
way we're gonna have to do it next Trump
says that Rudy Giuliani was the best
mayor of New York ever and that New York
has now collapsed which is news to
everybody in New York yeah went away
from his policy of guns you know what he
was doing with the gun stuff which
basically was started by Rudy look Rudy
was the greatest mayor in the history of
New York and the crimes I mean I don't
know how you were there you were there
when the city started to collapse I saw
it collapse I saw it come back Rooney
song and you've seen a collapse again
now it's collapsing again yeah now it's
uh at a level and the one thing that's
different
we had a very powerful police force that
wasn't being utilized now many of those
great policemen and women have left and
Gone to Texas it's mostly not true and
NYPD is actually doing fine but remember
that there's actually some interesting
political history here which is that
Rudy Giuliani benefited uh dramatically
uh and it's crazy to say it because it
was such a tragic event Rudy Giuliani
benefited dramatically in the way that
George W bush did
from 9 11 right George W bush saw 80
plus percent approval in the immediate
wake of 9 11 squandered it with the Iraq
War and Rudy Giuliani also became mayor
911 and ultimately it became all he
talked about for for about a decade
um but that is certainly a uh a claim
that New York is collapsing which is
hard to find anywhere as far as data or
facts are concerned Trump pulling out
the idea that America has gone communist
and what's really interesting to me
about this is you'll say well but David
Trump's been saying America's communist
for you know since Joe Biden the day Joe
Biden was inaugurated what's interesting
is to see Bannon in the context of
having to react to it one of the
greatest and I think if we win in uh 24
I think it's going to be when we win a
24 yeah the country can't take I don't
think it can take it no I don't think I
don't think we're going to have a
country you know this is a businessman I
don't think well even as a politician
they've weaponized you would know this
very well they've weaponized the justice
department they've weaponized the FBI
they're doing things that are communist
country would do a Marxist country would
do it's a very did you ever think this
country will get to that I never thought
it would be that bad and you've dealt
with some tough people yeah now here is
where I know Bannon is just doing the
sycophant suck up stuff Bannon Trump may
not be smart enough to know that there's
nothing Marxist going on in the United
States
Bannon is smart enough to know that
there's nothing Marxist happening in the
United States and so that's where I
start to see this and say Bannon is
absolutely playing a character here
he's playing the sycophant suck up
character here's Trump with his covid
conspiracies for lack of a better term
talking about Hunter Biden and saying it
was Russian disappear I always think
what do you think Putin is saying when
every week they came up with another
thing Russia Russia Russia they never
blamed anything in China because they
were all getting rich from China the one
way you can tell he's illegitimate is
the lack of respect
that they have for him throughout the
world boy now that's factually untrue
if you actually survey people around the
world
respect for the American presidency and
the country has recovered dramatically
since Joe Biden became president they
just lot they love telling this lie you
went to we went to Saudi Arabia I mean
the military's out the thing I think
they go he's in an SUV with a fist bump
the mullahs don't respect him the KGB in
Moscow does effect were you sure who's
right here for the historic Summit no
respect for him it's been three days
here we had a great we developed a great
relationship no one's covered came it
was like you know that was that was a
step too far I mean that cost the world
millions of lives and about
60 trillion dollars so nobody can ever
pay for that the lives of 60 trillion
dollars but they'll pay something
they'll pay something you know I got
would you demand reparations from China
you can't there's no such thing as 60
trillion dollars you could add 20
China's okay you can't but they cost the
world I figured it costs 60 trillion
dollars worldwide and you know millions
and millions of lives what came out of
the wall hand lab you remember I was the
first one as I said came from the
Warhead Library it came right out of
wall hand so Trump uh you know kind of
Reviving that one then there's a moment
which I can't play in its entirety
because uh I don't want anybody to you
know have a medical event from watching
five minutes of this but he he starts
lying about immigration for five
straight minutes and it's really crazy
we can take care of American citizens
people don't realize you also use
tariffs to help secure the border 100
the the Mexico started getting you know
well they would have never done it I
said to the president of Mexico who I
really like I have to tell you he's
great you know he wouldn't I don't think
to this day he's even acknowledged he
said that election was a rigged election
he said it happened to him 10 years
before and he's a socialist but you know
what uh he's a terrific guy but I said
listen uh we're building a wall and we
built I built hundreds of miles of world
that was my first hint that what they
wanted to do is let people pour into our
country from prisons from mental
institutions there we go what they have
only the best only the best only the
best insane asylum you know what I'm
saying Islam that's Silence of the Lamb
type okay and I don't know why nobody
goes sir it's Silence of the Lambs not
Silence of the Lamb so continuing to
tell those very same lies about uh the
Border none of that is happening and
then he moved on to a new favorite
Target where he lies about electric
vehicles and the electric vehicle lies
are interesting to me because it's such
a silly scapegoat and it's so obvious
that this is the way that vehicle
technology is going it just seems like
one of these fights that's a very dumb
fight to pick it'll only work for a
little while everything's the opposite
of what it should be we don't want to be
energy independent we want to spend on
set of 1.87 a gallon we want to spend
nine dollars a gallon we want to go to
all electric cars that go for two hours
and then you get stuck in the middle of
a road and there's nobody you might as
well forget the car how do you get it it
doesn't have I mean quite literally
doesn't happen you know my electric
car's range is 330 miles uh went New
York City to Montreal all with you know
One Stop which was an optional stop but
for a diaper change not for me but for
the baby it why are they attacking
electric cars because they've generated
an environment in which people like to
hear it and like to see it Without
Really apparently understanding the
truth of it now no Trump interview is
complete without big dumps
I'll give you an example do you think we
have tough enough to get this done I
don't know that's look the one thing the
Democrats have horrible policy but they
stick together
and they cheat the Republicans don't
want to achieve I said to a man in
Pennsylvania I love Pennsylvania I did
great I was up by almost 900 000 votes
all of a sudden I was even I said what
happened and you see the chart and then
there was a dump big dump I mean it was
amazing yeah Trump was amazed by the
size of the Pennsylvania dump uh he did
attack Alvin Bragg I'm gonna skip over
that even though I have it in my notes
he did attack Ron DeSantis and that's
another interesting moment here and it's
curious to see Steve bannon's reaction
to that we're going to take a look at
the DeSantis attacks and again remember
Trump obsessed with the santus despite
the fact that he's still not announced
anything because this is the Donald
Trump that America first met and now
you're under assault from everywhere
total assault total assault because
we're winning in the polls if I wasn't
enough
62 16. well the Sanctus is uh failing
badly Rhonda sanctimonious I mean you
know it's always bad you endorse
somebody he's dead he's he's over his
political he's going to be looking for a
job he'll be lucky to get a job
comes to me begs me for a endurance
going to give it to him he ends up
winning the election winning the
nomination winning the election by
numbers that you wouldn't believe I mean
he was so far down he was gone
and then they shout to him a couple of
years later where do you run against the
president I have no comment now no
comment means the answer is yes now that
is what this is all about that is the
the most honest thing Trump has said in
a long time this is the narcissism
full-fledged how dare DeSantis not
simply say I will not challenge our
great orange leader Donald Trump that's
what Trump expects that's what Trump
considers to be loyalty all right last
thing continuing to make these silly
promises about how quickly he will solve
the situation in Ukraine he would have
never gone into vice president in a
million years and even the Democrats
they did a poll the other day 94 say if
Trump was President you wouldn't have
that horrible catastrophe and so many
people have been killed many more than
they report when they blow up a city
Steve and you see all those big
buildings and then they say two people
were injured it's it's much worse than
anybody understands I would have that
settled in 24 hours yep and of course
and this came up in my interview with
Lex Friedman the insistence on Putin
wouldn't have invaded Ukraine had I been
president it's not really the big gotcha
that some of them believe it to be
because it's completely plausible that
Putin would have seen other ways to grow
his power if Trump were president rather
than Joe Biden so a bizarre interview
with Stephen Bannon but where Trump is
right and at the end of the day when the
rubber meets the road it's the numbers
that matter uh the polling Donald Trump
has opened a 36-point lead over Ron
DeSantis in a new poll
um these are stunning numbers
58 to 22.
58-22 Trump is leading DeSantis in a new
poll an even bigger lead than what we
have seen recently CBS News yougov poll
of 2300 voters
I am continuing to tell you that we can
look at all aspects of this but unless
something seriously changes unless
something really changes I don't see a
path for anyone other than Trump to win
that Republican nomination including
DeSantis de Sanctus Des sanctimonious
whatever you want to call the guy he
doesn't have a path to the 50 percent he
needs unless he can take support from
Donald Trump when you're at 58 percent
As Trump is
you don't need any more voters you've
already got what you need now of course
if you only have it in certain States
and not others and the timing of the
primaries okay there's this these narrow
narrow narrow scenarios but much like I
was honest with you in the 2020
Democratic primary when I saw that it
wasn't looking like Bernie had a path
and many people got mad at me it's not
looking mathematically like DeSantis has
a path unless something happens with
Trump
either some self-inflicted error
multiple arrests that take them off the
campaign Trail indefinitely something
like that Trump already has enough
Republican support to win the nomination
without convincing a single additional
voter so we will see where things look
in a month as we will be closer to when
I guess DeSantis would be announcing if
he plans to but as of right now it's
hard to imagine what's going to get in
Trump's way of being the Republican
nominee once again
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Bob
zeidman who's the creator of the field
of software forensics the founder of
several high-tech firms author of
textbooks and screenplays novels a high
stakes poker player in Vegas and also
the guy we mentioned who I guess we
could say won the prove Mike wrong
challenge which was The Challenge from
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell known to many
of us simply as pillow almost like
Madonna
where he offered up five million dollars
to anyone that could prove that the data
he claimed showed China interfered with
the 2020 presidential election was not
proving that Bob you you proved that
essentially and now you are in the
process of if I understand attempting to
collect this five million dollar prize
which a court has said is due to you if
that's the latest I've read
yes David thanks for having me on the
show and that's correct technically it
was an arbitration but it was binding
arbitration uh three arbitrators made
that decision you know and one thing I
think sometimes isn't always clear I'll
just say this is that uh you know the
the contest was not to prove that there
was no fraud but it was actually broader
than that that the data didn't even have
anything to do with the 2020 election
and you know I've interviewed Mike
pillow a number of times and he always
says listen I'll send you the data and
then you and of course I I don't know
what I would do with it because I'm not
a cyber guy as he says but he never
sends the data first question is where
did you actually get the data that was
meant to be analyzed
so he provided it indirectly he had a
team of people who uh gave it to a bunch
of experts he invited a bunch of experts
supposedly we were all vetted so we
couldn't come to this Symposium that he
held about almost two years ago in Sioux
Falls South Dakota you couldn't come
unless you were vetted as an expert and
then he he gave us the data but at the
arbitration there were a lot of excuses
for why I uh well why it wasn't evident
that this was election data let me put
it that way I mean he said it was
election data but there were a lot of uh
excuses that he didn't give us the whole
data because of National Security issues
because he was afraid of hacking because
he thought that China or somebody was
threatening him uh that it was encrypted
decoded uh modified
so but these these these claims as silly
as they are they do seem to go to
Lindell really does believe this stuff
this isn't a joke for him because this
is something people often ask me since
I've spoken to him a couple of times do
I think he's kidding or do I think he
believes this stuff he does seem to
believe this stuff
yeah so that was a big question all the
experts had that question I can say we
as far as I know unanimously decided
this was not election data I was the one
person who figured out what it actually
was and wrote up a detailed report and
submitted it
but you know the question was was Mike
Bamboozled or was he bamboozling people
yes but he seems to be a True Believer
but the only thing is
any rational person at this point would
know the data is fake but Mike has
basically fired or insulted or
ostracized to anyone who's come to him
including people on his team who've said
that it's fake data so the the data that
was provided what was it what was it
data about what was the the general area
that it pointed to
well there were a number of files that
we got I got five files the first day
and or seven files the first day I
forget now and four files a second it
wasn't a whole lot of files but one of
you know some were PDFs showing generic
voting machine processes uh but the
inter the more interesting ones is we
got a bunch of files that contain what
are called hex data but it was viewable
hex data and so I translated it I got
the idea to translate it to actual
binary data and the way I would describe
that is if you got a bunch of files that
had written out in English language
words
1254 61 and then you translated those to
the actual numbers you know that that's
equivalent to what I did then I took
those files Tran and I noticed that they
were old-fashioned because I've been in
this business for a while old-fashioned
word processing documents so I put them
in a word processor Microsoft Word and
lo and behold what came up were one file
was a table thousands of numbers that
were just numbers I mean just a table of
numbers that didn't mean anything
and the other files were thousands of
pages in one case of gibberish as if
someone had just sat there for hours
typing typing typing then reverse the
process I just did to make it look like
sophisticated computer data so some of
that there's not even really a reason to
think it relates to elections at all
never mind an American election
right no it definitely didn't although
again at arbitration was what was
fascinating is different members of
either Lindell and different members of
lindell's team would come up with
excuses like the gibberish was really
encrypted data that they had purposely
encrypted or China had encrypted or you
know depending on who was talking that I
wasn't smart enough to see it but the
problem was they never they never
demonstrated what it really was they
said oh it's just sophisticated
encrypted data and their excuse was well
we don't have to tell you what it is
because zeidman it was his job to do it
if if he wanted to claim the five
million dollars and the arbitrators
basically if you read their decision
they said even lindell's team couldn't
demonstrate what this was other than
gibberish I'm curious whether as as news
broke of your involvement in this and
the arbitration decision about the 5
million did did you start getting
threats from people or angry messages
because it seems hard to do anything
these days without someone being
absolutely Furious did the did any of
the Believers try to contact you or
threaten you
so that's an interesting question so
first of all you know I'm a I'm a
republican conservative uh I've I've
sudden people who were not so happy with
me in the past couple years I do a lot
of writing on political and social
issues suddenly we're friendly and
telling me what a great job I did but I
have to say even the conservatives the
vast majority of them were thankful some
of them believe that Lindell is hurting
Trump and hurting the Republicans and I
can tell you about that in a minute if
you want but the other thing I'll say is
I've gotten like two or three
threatening emails or Twitter messages
nothing that I take seriously mostly
people say they hate me I'm a Trader
sure but but I went to a conservative
conference a very with some very you
know strong conservatives and even uh
people who advise Trump
and at first I didn't want to mention
what I've done
but it came out and the vast majority of
them shook my hand and thanked me for
what I'd done and a few of them started
questioning why did you do this and I
read this and I heard Lindell and when I
talked to them by the end of the
conference without exception all of them
thanked me interesting now you met you
mentioned that your your uh conservative
you voted for Trump twice right
yeah yeah I did I can tell you that the
first time I you know I don't without
going into detail I did not like Trump I
followed his business practices and I've
had some problems I've you know in a
very very tiny scale I've done business
with his businesses and I didn't
find his practices ethical but I thought
it was uh but I really didn't trust
Hillary Clinton and I thought the
Republicans would keep an eye on Trump
and the Democrats would not keep tabs on
Hillary
um did you find that that's the way it
played out
yeah you know it's it's difficult to say
so because when Trump ran there was a
lot of Republican opposition to him yeah
and of course there were the never
trumpers but with Hillary the Democratic
party really universally supported her
as what I saw
um now
you know Trump has basically made this
effort to take control of the Republican
party which I don't like because I think
it's all about him and not about
ideology anymore so I'm I voted for him
again reluctantly the second time but
I'm hoping to have a third option uh
neither Republican or Democrat uh if
it's Trump V Biden I really don't like
either candidate so I'm hoping there'll
be a third uh option that's interesting
so have would you say that you've
suffered under the first two years of
Biden in a way that makes you think I've
really got to get someone else in there
you know I do I I think that Biden you
know Biden was always a middle of the
road
person you know politically until he ran
for president this time and it just
seems like a lot of uh far-left policies
are being implemented or at least
being given uh you know the okay from
the White House really now that's
interesting to me this is super because
I would love for Biden to be far left
I don't see him as being that way I'm
curious what would be a policy that you
see as far left that was implemented
what I mostly see is that well first of
all I don't like the spending bills that
he's uh implemented so I'm a member of
an organization called No Labels which
brings together Republicans and
Democrats I'm familiar with it okay and
so the problem solvers caucus of no
labels in Congress helped pass the first
budget uh bill which was in December of
2022 I believe and then but then Biden
passed his other one which was a lot
more spending on programs I don't like
are you talking about the inflation
reduction act here yes yes okay so I
mean I don't like that I think we're
we're really you know we've gone way
over budget
um
you know we're going to break the debt
ceiling obviously uh I really don't like
all that government spending but also
although you know me you know well first
of all I think there are a lot of things
I think to pull out of in Afghanistan
was horrific we lost more people in that
pull out than we had I think in the past
year in Afghanistan
um I don't like enabling the Taliban in
Afghanistan I don't like the Border
policy we've had more illegal
immigration and then we've had I think
in American history how do you know that
um you know I can't quote sources
offhand but I have researched it so one
thing I do is I really try to look into
I I publish articles and I really try to
do the research to find these numbers
before I uh talk about them yeah well
you know I mean I'm not trying to play
gotcha and really I mean this is just
interesting to me really you're here to
talk about the the Mike pillow stuff but
what's interesting to me is clearly
you're a smart guy and you're
technologically inclined and you sort of
understand how we figure out whether
something is true but like when you say
the Biden spending the rate at which the
debt has grown
slowed down under Biden it's still
growing right we're talking about the
difference between debt and deficit of
course the debt is still growing under
Biden but a little more slowly than
under Trump you'd think a guy like you
who clearly is so fact-oriented would
say hey you know what I I don't like it
but it is better than what we were
seeing under Trump is that fair
well
you know I've I've heard those arguments
before and the problem is even
Republicans have are have been bad on
spending sure that's an issue for me and
I think that politicians in general
uh the best they can they've ever done
is reduce the increase in the deficit
but it's still a dangerously increasing
deficit in my mind sure I mean I'd love
to see uh politicians get in and
Congress represent in the presidency
that could actually cut programs look I
I'm willing I'm a republican who's
willing to cut spending on the military
because although I think our military
needs to be strong it also needs to
spend efficiently sure and just throwing
more money at it and this is a problem
that I see like you know I'll criticize
the Republicans here
the Republicans have to go into an
election if they want to win saying
we're going to spend more money on the
military but in reality I'd love to see
them say we're going to spend less money
on the military for more efficient
operations I mean and by the way I could
I could have another show I sued the US
government for fraud
um because I uncovered fraud it's a
longer story but it was well but that's
I mean that's interesting without
getting into that your view on the
military is not one I expect to hear
from any presidential Republican
candidate even if they believe it
because it wouldn't be politically
viable to say it question for you are
you sort of a little bit concerned about
the degree to which the quote anti-woke
platform is taking over the Republican
party or do you like that
well I like that oh you do I know I know
we disagree on that but you know
something
I can tell you I've written about this
so
um and I'll put it in my personal
perspective I'm Jewish and I even
criticized Jewish groups that are just I
understand them they want they want to
eliminate anti-Semitism which is a great
cause
but in doing so there's this race to be
the world's greatest or the country's
greatest victim and I think this
victimhood mentality is increasing the
racial conflict
in the country and I don't know how to
get away from it because each group I
think looks at another group and says
well that group is getting money and
they're getting publicity and so we need
to outspend them and outdo them get more
attention so that we get more you know
attention for our issues so if the
victimhood stuff isn't appealing when
Trump says he was treated more unfairly
than Lincoln who was shot dead in the
head you're not huge on that I'm
guessing no look Trump says you know I'm
gonna I have some friends who I have one
in particular he's probably not going to
speak to me anymore but Trump's is
incredibly childish stuff yeah I really
you know it's scary because I'll tell
you in the four years he was in office I
generally liked his policies but but the
problem is he doesn't know how to run a
country and bring us together true and
and he's very very divisive he's very
childish and the other thing is the you
know I hope you can appreciate this he
he likes Gavin Newsom who is
ideologically should be on the opposite
end of the political Spectrum but I
think that's an issue Trump likes people
not and dislikes people not based on
their ideology or principles but based
on whether they treat him nicely
absolutely correct absolutely correct
Bob last thing in the in the few moments
we have on the five million bucks do you
expect to collect it
no I'm pretty sure that Lindell is going
to lose his cases with dominion and
smartmatic and I think he's going to be
bankrupt and you know if I see anything
it'll be Pennies on the dollar all right
all right we've been speaking with Bob
zeidman who uh he he fought pillow and
he won but we will see where the money
lands Bob I really appreciate your time
today okay thanks David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's look at what it looks
like when a non-religious person who is
a republican tries to Pander to
religious voters it's actually quite
depressing Donald Trump appeared on the
I never fully understand what show this
is the flashpoint victory
show it's a religious Christian thing
and it's actually hilarious what happens
they one of the questions is framed
about how important Trump's faith is to
him and it's really funny because
obviously it's not true Trump has never
been religious but he's started to
pretend to be religious because he ran
as a republican this just gets like
really awkward and Trump spits out a
word salad about religion your faith is
very important to you you've said that
publicly your faith is important Trump
has said a lot of things that aren't
true but what does that mean to the man
Donald Trump well I think it means a lot
of things but more to perhaps your
listeners and the people that will watch
the show and that's a very large group
of people uh for instance I was the only
president ever go go to go to the big
rally they had in Washington right which
they have on a yearly basis but I guess
he means the March for Life I guess the
only one ever to go as a president
sitting president for life and people
were shocked but even Ronald Reagan
didn't want to take that step and it was
very close always very close as you know
to the White House it's almost like
walking distance but I went and I was
proud of that I think we've been given
credit for doing that but you can tell
Trump is deeply religious deeply
spiritual from this answer people would
say that was a courageous thing to do I
think you were just courageous I
reviewed it as the right thing to do but
I was
born into a family where my father was
religious my mother was religious uh I
wouldn't say they were you know going to
church every single day they were you
know they were believers they were very
privately religious such that no one
knew it even me and and strong believers
I went to Sunday school
which was good and which was expected
you know it's like you everybody goes to
story school right and when you think
about it the world is so different now
anyway so you know you get the just they
slammed Hillary Clinton for adopting a
sort of Southern drawl when she would
speak in front of some Southern crowds
in my mind that's nothing compared to
pretending to be devoutly religious and
against abortion when clearly you you
aren't and you haven't been your entire
life Trump of course there's no you
never waste the opportunity to claim
that the left is simply against religion
they're against religion they're totally
against religion how do you get elected
on these things they get elected by
cheating right of course the truth is
what my listen you can ask different
people on the left you'll get different
answers I'm against religion playing a
role in civil government I love freedom
of religion freedom to follow any
religious doctrine that speaks to you or
not to follow any and to have none of
that impact public policy nor how you
were treated under the law that's what
I'm for as a member of the left I'm not
against religion Trump then said he's
the only person who can stop Israel from
getting nuked by Iran which is
interesting and there's a lot to say
about this
under the Democrats Israel will be
destroyed because Iran will have a
nuclear weapon and they'll destroy
Israel they will use it too so when you
say I fight I fight because we have no
choice we have no choice
and there's nobody else I don't believe
that knows
how to do this right so it's really
important to understand that the way in
which Trump supporters are quote
pro-israel is a very specific thing from
the Evangelical Christian Community the
the viewers of this show okay the
viewers of this show support Israel not
because of any concern about
anti-Semitism or Jews or it's because
they believe that supporting Israel will
precipitate the second coming of Christ
after which most or all of the Jews die
depending on which belief system you
adhere to that's why they are quote
supporters of Israel and that's what
Trump is paying lip service to and then
lastly Trump saying the Johnson
amendment is a terrible thing if you
don't know what that is I'll tell you in
a moment I'm asking why don't you use
your power so that you can be treated
better
and then one person said well we have
the Johnson Amendment which basically
would take our tax exemption and our tax
basis away from us and which is
unbelievably severe and put put you out
of business
I said so that actually the people and I
was at the top of Trump Tower way up
high and I looked down at the sidewalk
and you see all the people I said so
anybody off the street then you're
saying has more power than the people in
this room because okay so let me explain
to you what Trump is saying here the
Johnson amendment is a tax code
provision from 1954. when we say
non-profit churches aren't allowed to do
politics or they jeopardize their
tax-exempt status what we're talking
about partially comes from the Johnson
Amendment the Johnson Amendment said if
you're a 501c3 nonprofit organization
you can't endorse or oppose political
candidates and of course as We Know
dozens and dozens hundreds thousands of
churches particularly Evangelical
churches
um and other forms of Christianity
protestantism regularly do politics and
often overtly endorse or oppose
candidates they should lose their
tax-exempt status Trump is saying no
it's too harsh because then it actually
uh makes them impotent in some way
relative to random people well the whole
point is we will give you something
special something privileged under the
tax code which is non-profit status but
you can't engage in politics because
that's a way to circumvent all of the
campaign Finance infrastructure that is
there for a particular reason so Trump
doesn't like that Trump wants to get rid
of that this is the height
or the bottom of the barrel depending on
your view of pandering to a group of
Voters that yes Trump does need he
rightly assesses that he needs them in
the most pathetic way possible all right
one more quick story there's a new
report from Vanity Fair that Donald
Trump snatched a reporter's phone during
a tantrum that took place during an
interview and again you know it's like
this is like the Secret Service story
told by Cassidy Hutchinson about Trump
lunging for a secret service guy you
were always told oh it's so out of
character for Trump he would never do
that that would never happen oh it's
just it's obviously a lie and yet we get
more and more and more of these stories
of trump lashing out physically in some
way when he throws a tantrum so here's
the Vanity Fair uh report from Charlotte
Klein get him out of here Donald Trump
tossed NBC reporters phones during a
tirade above his campaign plane in a
recording obtained by Vanity Fair the
former president lashed out at Von
Hilliard over his questions related to
The Manhattan DA's case demonstrating
the ex-president's hostile attitude
towards the Press remains unchanged
going into 2024.
um it was March Trump was aboard his
plane with a gaggle of reporters after
the Waco Texas rally he started off in
good spirits reads the article but then
a line of questioning from NBC news
reporter Von Hilliard who suggested
Trump had in recent days seemed
frustrated by Alvin Bragg's
investigation began irritating Trump
don't ask me any more questions Trump
said 10 minutes later as Hilliard
continued asking about the investigation
Trump snapped grabbed the reporters two
phones Chuck them to the side according
to a source familiar with the matter get
him out of here Trump told his aides
according to a recording obtained by
Vanity Fair this happened a few days
before the indictment so listen is this
a major story no but anytime we get more
detail and more texture as some may call
it about Trump's temper it becomes
increasingly clear that it's completely
plausible that what Cassidy Hutchinson
said about Trump lunging at a secret
service agent on that day
is absolutely plausible now whether it's
true is a different question but people
know that lying under oath is a crime uh
and the reflexive of course they're
making this stuff up out of thin air
here is an example of trump exhibiting
the exact same sort of tantrum Behavior
um and this one includes a recording
that was obtained by Vanity Fair making
it much more clear that this is exactly
how Trump behaved so we don't have to
spend a ton of time on this as I've said
before it's we're just building up a
picture uh of how many of the things
that Trump supporters immediately say
are obvious lies turn out to be almost
certainly true Trump lashing out and
snatching two phones from an NBC news
reporter we have a voicemail number
which is 2192 David P you know I
mentioned that it's interesting that
when all of those Maga people came into
the city into New York City sorry for uh
Trump's arrest a few weeks ago despite
all of them claiming all the time New
York City's so dangerous it's dangerous
it's crazy in New York City we didn't
hear about any of those people that came
into the city for Trump's arrest
even witnessing a single crime never
mind being victimized by it here's a
caller who says he did see a crime when
he was in New York City listen to this
David I I heard you say how you haven't
really witnessed Prime in New York City
and I think you're being a little
disingenuous uh for example a few weeks
ago I was in New York with some friends
and we witnessed a man in broad daylight
being held up and robbed right across
the street and we marveled at it and
then what's really shocking is we were
all arrested for breaking the Good
Samaritan law because we didn't help him
have you ever heard of anything like
this before I mean I have this is a
Seinfeld episode sounds crazy to me uh
my lawyer said it was Preposterous
ludicrous outrageous I'm still waiting
to you know to get bailed out here so
yeah so that's I'm sure that was
attorney Jackie Childs who said that no
listen I mean
all over New York City not really Staten
Island I've only been there once I just
took the ferry got off and got right
back on but um Manhattan Brooklyn Queens
and the Bronx where I've been to some
Yankees games uh when the Sox are in
town I have never witnessed a single
crime now have I seen mental illness
that sometimes becomes aggressive I have
yeah that's true have I seen bodily
fluids on the subway yes I have uh but
when we're talking about you know the
sort of rampant criminality that the
Wright loves to say is just everywhere
in New York City uh I've never seen it
do I know I mean I guess I know I know
probably someone who's been pickpocketed
or something like that the point is not
to pretend there's no murder in violent
crime in New York City but the point is
when you look at crime rates there's
cities in Ohio with higher crime rates
we know about Oklahoma City Oklahoma
with higher crime rates Etc that's the
point
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today I won't even waste time by telling
you what's on it other than to say we
are going to talk about the writers
strike the late night comedy writers
strike and many other things sign up at
joinpakman.com get instant access and it
will be a beautiful day
thank you